estou a fazer isso o que eu faço não
tinha filhos a tranquila fácil mas o
lado pessoal de quem falou da crise
muito bem-vindos canais um vídeo e
fotografia pela noite para fazer um
pedido de pressa salto então eu tenho
que ter algum material de seus filhos
pra vocês
ai ai
a primeira é um estilo que explicam e
aston villa e estilac bem com o mp4
se vocês podem me muito quando vão à
escola e que o design é muito louco em
vinil se destruído por qualquer coisa
cosme cancelar a ficar mais atenção e
não é só os times têm muita coisa aqui
dentro eu vou falar pra vocês tudo
material escolar que vocês precisam é um
material escolar de cheney o que fazer
dentro comprarem os próximos chila esta
que é uma das minhas favoritas
professores outra juiz crê esgotos porém
diz que a escola num muito muito muito
muito prático porque estava escrevendo
um homem fazer uma curva se e mas com
sol e mochila e eu acho que os primeiros
inscritos na minha altura da escola que
não vinham estas coisas não podem vir só
vocês correm para a escola em grande
estilo próximo scheyla é somente no
prazo limite não esquece vocês ok vocês
podem ter uma mochila mostra que nessa
última vem com o microfone
vocês sabem como eu falei ontem muitos
setores de muita entrega do aço o volume
projetado otto uma coluna aqui já
assumida para cantar vou jogar para
tentar novo aqui ou noutro vocês vão
fazer coisas muito boas
ah ah ah quero que você vá cantava aqui
é sempre assim fazem o que gostam de
fraco é incrível eu quero que você vá vá
comprar da noite o cantor foi assim
aprendem por exemplo já sabem mas vocês
podem ser a nova super parque de geração
ainda tem um estilo bem louca que tem
que se cuidar sim na próxima e última
noite lula eu acho que tem material
essa linha de frente das outras por ter
uma troca aí porque aí essa que tem umas
rodas tudo menor é só tem uma gente sabe
mas que quer e tem aqui um padrão fifa
tropa e para quem gosta do podia muito
positiva eu gosto de aspecto material em
32 o ladrão tem muito mas até agora só
há muita coisa que sinto mais grupal
mesmo a primeira coisa que eu escolhi
foi este lábios mas se vocês olharem mãe
não falar por mais esta questão baquetas
de bateria pobre que eu não sei se o
profissional está muito em linha com o
cenário do canal méxico podem fazer leis
próxima coisa que eu escolhi também
foram duas canetas que vejam só são 500
do esqueleto e dá pra fazer uma coisa
muito engraçada com os vossos amigos
quero uma vaga de canetas na aula
eu escuto conquista o pugilista morreu
[Música]
eu escolhi também é que estes dois lados
que eu achei muito engraçado porque na
verdade não são lápis ou lapiseira já
não é tão bonita e dos nossos amigos vão
pensar que vocês têm que ver com lápide
nba dá uma caneta e quando pensava em
escrever mesmo um lado na verdade é uma
vilã então vocês podem ir aos 20min
próximo isso não sei bem ao certo o que
queremos você piada falei que é uma
régua de uma draga ainda bem que os
clientes se você consegue medir tudo na
escola mas dá pra fazer muita coisa
passa uma coisa que eu queria que eu sei
muito engraçado foi um balão eo funk
[Música]
a próxima coisa pessoal que eu escolhi
pra vocês querem ser em outubro disse
que a companhia muito os meus vídeos
clique aqui uma caneta tem uma câmera
olha só não sei se funciona ou talvez
vocês podem ser muito louco pra vocês
cuidarem todos os dois lápis e canetas e
explique um estojo ruban blanc deus o
douro então acho que tenha medo e quando
você fosse um robô com os dentes
componente eu seria melhor se deus
quiser eu vou usar o google abre ela
fizer é é é não mexer no cabelo assim a
escola pessoal
a próxima coisa que eu criei o marcador
supergigante
cheira cheira cheira bem cheira a
morango será morango com um resultado
merecido caneta eu quero comer esta
caneta e sem café podem escrever cartas
de amor para as pessoas passavam por um
português porque se chama amor é de
vocês conseguem a conquista é e sempre
ajuda a próxima coisa que eu criei um
quadro vocês forem escrever coisas a
xxxviii 15 metros depois claro que não
posso fazer coisas muito engraçadas ser
executado em toda a cidade o que mais
nos mais coisas que passei lá o ênio
estão escrevendo aqui sou eu preciso
definir pois você já sabe o que mais tem
caixa mesmo deixei muito mais que nos
calhou fora próxima entre outro material
que eu achei muito engraçado para você
usar na escola olha aí costa costa ser e
eu chorei aqui o que nunca aconteceu na
escola isso você amiga flerta com
comichão vocês podem ficar a equipe só
então é deixar em que os dois é fácil
apanhar bolas
o chão e agora em greve na próxima
reunião que eu sei eu tenho certeza que
eu não posso experimentar sun estes
gomes de picante ou pios só eu não posso
comer expor como vocês sabem sou médico
picantes acompanhante quando ele deve
preencher o mesmo vou escalar vou
arriscar só porque foi um desafio da
noite onde enfrentará avaí
uma lei como a moda é só a língua é
proibida a produção está a passar é bom
saber que tem conduzido o ipca não só
love já está aqui é muito doce é muito
bom mas fica muito então cuidado a tomar
os nossos pacotes beyoncé vai pra final
vamos ter as duas coisas que eu acho de
buttars mesmo tipo de minhas favoritas
uma delas é os cadernos de raquete ponto
dá pra jogar tempo com cadernos da
escola mesmo um poder estão caderno
equipe à frente perdeu sete pontos numa
escala muito bem e evita um caderno com
erro e vai outra marketing cotas podem
jogar com os times na aula mesmo pelo
canto isto é um gênio então gênio no
brasil então já tem porque ser a
inventar histórias mas foi próximo à
final que os clipes o álbum só eu também
gosto muito uma caneta mas esta não é
uma criança qualquer esta canetas quando
os credores não é só uma caneta
como vocês podem ver com uma caneta de
greve mas escolhida nesta canetas está
em um nível quando vocês podem medir e
manipular as coisas então se eu colocar
aqui eu sei que está lá irei publicar
aquilo que quis da turnê por várias
vezes e ordenada
vocês precisavam consertar alguma coisa
que não faço 40 km para só aí é sobre
repartimento vendas que vai colocar uma
chapa apenas uma caneta aí tem duas
esta planta e esta ponte é meu deus é
muito longo e funções muito todas as
áreas só se precisarem de arranjar
alguma coisa tá que tá quieto ele
acredita que é mais pessoal essas foram
algumas escolhas para o material escolar
deste ano já sabe vocês podem contar
isso tudo não é novo mas sei lá eu
garanto sol
com este material possa ficar genius
gênio jaqueline gente vocês na escola
vão passar a internet para que o estado
forneça crítico no final escreveu deixei
muito mais que também fez fiquem bem
está prof
ainda estou fazendo planos ano
[Música]